[Musique]
le président du Département a reçu au
palais de la source l'équipe de beach
soccer les Minos de Marseille en
déplacement sur Lille pour un tournoi
l'équipe des 10 joueurs compte parmi eux
un réunionné Jérémy basquez ça fait
plaisir grave plaisir parce que bon
d'habitude c'est moi qui qui va à
Marseille là c'est eux qui viennent chez
nous donc c'est c'est important de bien
les accueillir et et faire voir notre
culture et notre savoirffaire ici à la
Réunion un mot sur le tournoi c'est quoi
les objectifs
ben de gagner parce queon est sur une
bonne dynamique cette saison on a fini
champion d'Europe champion de France et
on est dans la continuité on est en
train de travailler pour l'année
prochaine et d'essayer et de rorter ce
tournoi voilà merci de passer par chez
nous bienvenue au département c'est une
fierté pour moi de voir bah des
footballeurs de haut niveau c'est pas
tous les joueurs qu'on peut accueill à
des des équipes de de la métropole élu
meilleur joueur en 2023 Jérémy basquez
et ses coéquipes ont échangé avec le
président sur leur saison et sur le
match de gala qui aura lieu vendredi 15
à 20h sur le front de mer de
[Musique]
Saint-Paul